this is from the daily wire
a british reading out a british fashion
journalist
faced a storm of outrage thursday after
suggesting that children should be
watching entry-level pornography
a contributor to gq
and the sunday time style magazine she
posted a twitter quote
someone needs to create oh there it is
someone needs to create porn for
children
hear me out
young teens are already watching porn
but they're finding hardcore aggressive
videos that give a terrible view of sex
they need entry-level porn a soft core
site where everyone asks for consent and
no one gets choked etc
now she put that out there
and then deleted it within i don't know
within minutes maybe
like an hour top she she deleted it
really quickly
um
which which shows
this is the the bubble
that these people are living in
you know someone in the media a fashion
journalist
a living ice sub in london or something
and the the bubble she's in
that the bubble of degeneracy and
decadence that she's in
uh she she didn't know that people would
react
negatively to that
and you know she didn't expect it
because she deleted it right away
you know if somebody says something
controversial
and then leaves it up there
i it still might be grotesque and
outrageous and evil and insane like this
but at least you know that they knew it
was going to be controversial and they
were prepared for that they know what
they knew that what they were getting
into they leave it up there hey
it is what it is um they take it down
right away and that tells you that they
didn't think that this was going to be a
problem
she didn't think the circles that she
runs in
she thought that oh yeah entry-level
porn for kids what's the big deal
what oh you guys you guys have a problem
with that i had no idea
and later she kind of backtracked and
she was saying oh it's all about consent
i didn't mean to
insinuate this and that um
she also clarified this was supposed to
make it better oh by children i mean
just people under 18. so you know 14 15
16. uh okay well that makes it a lot
better
but if you look even at her
what she was saying after the fact
trying to justify it after she deleted
it
there were plenty of people
many of them kind of like in her orbit
you could tell journalist media people
defending her
and saying they think it sounds like a
good idea also
or at least they know what she was
getting at and you know it doesn't
offend them
of course it is offensive but there are
things the word offensive you know is
way overused people are offended by way
too many things there are things that
are legitimately offensive
proposing porn for children legitimately
actually offensive
if you have a soul if you have any kind
of functioning moral compass at all
you're going to find that offensive and
outrageous and disgusting
but i should also note you know
her her proposal here as outrageous and
disgusting and evil
and deranged
as it is
it's not that far from the view of many
people in fact
it's not that far
because
you you probably know my opinion on the
subject of pornography very much in the
anti-camp
and um
whenever i've talked about this
especially when you get into the risks
it posed to chill poses to children i
mean i've proposed in the fact in the
past
um
i proposed banning pornography outright
which i still believe we should do
of course most people
very upset at that notion don't take my
pornography from me it's all i have in
my life is the message you get from a
lot of people
but even if you if you
s you back up a little bit and you say
okay
putting banning porn to the side
what about just putting some measures in
place to protect children from it
some really basic measures not even
anything extreme
i'm in favor of the more extreme
measures but
but if we're not talking about that what
if we're talking about something really
some real basic stuff
for example
uh requiring that pornography sites like
pornhub
verify ages
before allowing people to enter the site
yeah there are ways around that it's not
foolproof but it's definitely better
than nothing
and there are many different ways that
that that websites can verify ages there
are websites now that will actually do
this depending on
uh what kind of site it is you want to
do online gambling for example
you're gonna have to verify who you are
and verify your age
so there are ways to do it
it's not that onerous
it shouldn't be a big deal
if you're an adult
and you want to look at porn what's the
big deal you have to verify your age
but when i've suggested this or what
anyone suggests that
people lots of people are opposed to it
they would rather the pornography
be open forever
they would rather be open and available
to everyone
knowing that millions of like
nine-year-olds are going to be going to
be exposed to the most depraved and
disgusting extreme pornography
imaginable
knowing that that's going to happen
because these measures are not put in
place
and there are millions of adults who are
okay with that
because the alternative is that their
own access might be slightly
impeded if you even for a lot of adults
if
if if you suggest even slightly impeding
their access to hardcore pornography
um
that to them is is
so offensive that they would rather the
alternative of having nine-year-olds
exposed to this
doing immense and immeasurable
psychological damage that will last for
their whole lives
so on one hand you've got this woman
saying let's intentionally expose young
children to pornography
but it'll be you know it'll be sort of
softer pornography
so you've got that and that's a horrible
thing to say
then you've gotta in my experience
a lot of adults who would say well let's
not intentionally expose them but at the
same time
uh i don't really care if they are
exposed to hardcore porn uh
i don't wanna do anything to stop that
from happening
those two viewpoints i would put about
on the same level in terms of their
depravity
and in terms of being utterly and
totally indefensible
any other industry
i mean really any other industry
where a product or service is being
provided
that is not legal for children to
consume
in any other industry they are required
to do something to verify the age
you want to buy liquor in fact forget
about that
if if pornography magazines even still
exist
and you went to a gas station
to buy one
they'd have to verify your age
you know if a nine-year-old went into a
gas station and bought a porn
magazine and the cashier just let him
buy it
uh who would defend that
and say well it's really the parent's
fault where are the parents yeah where
are the parents but at the same time how
does that justify what the cashier did
is it okay for the cashier to say well
your parents aren't here and uh whatever
sure i'll take your money
now in any other circumstance we expect
basic measures to be put in place
except with porn sites they are the one
exception
that doesn't make any sense
so
as horrifying as as this viewpoint is
it's really not far from what many
people believe and
you know and if you're in that camp
where you think we should do absolutely
nothing
from up from a you know a policy
perspective to insulate kids from this
then you're you're setting the stage for
people like this uh journalist here
just so you know
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content